what's a good tip on honing improv
skills just taking an improv class and
yeah and I mean improv as far as like
improv comedy is a little different than
improv in within the constraints of a
scene because improv comedy you're just
going for the laugh what is the what
what can I say that's funny improv
within the scene you need to make sure
you're still moving the story forward
you know you need to make sure what
you're saying isn't just let me throw in
a goofy thing here unless it is unless
that's what they want but if you're
going to go out on the limb and improv
on something in a more serious seen you
better make sure it's servicing the
story you know but yet to hone that I
would say improv great games are great
and a lot of fun and yeah there's
there's great classes and schools on
both coasts I mean UCB is where most of
my friends go in New York if they're
taking improv classes I have not taken
at any of the schools but I just we used
to do a lot of improv like in the camps
and stuff growing up but I think being
able to improv in the scene also comes
from back to being in the moment or
playing at the moment which we were
saying off camera before it's a lot like
I use those terms a lot of people use in
in your head you know so if you're in
your head and just playing at the moment
you're thinking of what's on the page
and what's you know what I what I need
to do if you're just being in the moment
the you you're able to just live that
seem like it's happening you know
you